what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel before i start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos
so today
we are talking about
the cost of success
in a different way
than i have i've talked about the price
of success before but
before i start guys send them for our
memberships um we have some members only
blogs if you want to see me
um probably the next like two weeks
we're dropping a number another vlog um
also
also um it helps us just be able to
predict
like right now we're hiring a lot of
people oh my god i'm so stressed out
about it but
i get nervous hiring people because
you never know if ads and views like
will go up and down but memberships are
like money i can count on so
i really would like to get a bigger
apartment next year um
which you're like why do i care about
your apartment well this is where i film
so i'd like to get a three bedroom
and make two of the rooms like into [ __ ]
i don't know um
so
if
yeah set up for memberships anyways
so today i'm talking about the price of
success but in a different way
than i normally talk about it
so
i have been
i
guess i am more stressed out than i've
ever been in my entire life and it's
funny because i have more success
career-wise anyways
than i've ever had in my entire life
like
it's like [ __ ] you guys wouldn't even
think about i i hate managing people
i hate it i have a manager and i
outsource a lot of that but even
there's like no avoiding it
there's none there's no avoiding it
there's always problems always [ __ ] you
gotta like
like it's weird because in management
right
you do less work
but you have to manage other people's
work and make sure they're doing their
work
and you're like thinking
well that sounds better than doing the
work yourself
i don't know
i don't think i'm built for it i really
don't enjoy that actually
but
you know you complain about i'm not even
trying to complain i'm just trying to
give you guys
an insight
into what
this stuff is like
another thing
people don't realize
is i think they think social media
influencers make more
like
most the social media influencers you
know ain't making [ __ ]
honestly i mean don't get me wrong
i've been blessed
but even when you're blessed like when
you take out money for taxes all the
money you have to pay people
and it's like the more money you get
everyone wants to cut
it's like everybody you talk to everyone
everyone wants a job everyone's raised
everyone wants this and it's crazy
because when you were on the co-op
when you were on the come-up
nobody was there
like that's a crazy thing i mean some
people were that's why i hired my friend
dress
because she helped me a lot early on
but
it's like people want the rewards of the
hard work but they didn't want to help
you when you were doing it
the other issue
is that the bigger you get like people
meet you and they have like a certain
perception of you and if you're having
like an off day or you're like whatever
they're so quick to turn on you even if
they're fans
like and and then you'll ask like and
you hear things with the grapevine i'm
like okay what did i do that was so
offensive
and the things that they list are like
nothing
huh
but
i don't know
so i don't know it's just like a
it's like a weird side of success to be
honest
like i heard
these [ __ ] are making a hate group
about me i'm like a hate group
do you have this much free time
sorry i shouldn't say [ __ ]
ladies
i don't know the internet
it's kind of a weird place and i always
try it my dad's like
who cares who cares like
none of these people matter who cares
and i think my dad's proud of me but
i feel like he doesn't men and women
just like process that sort of stuff
like differently
where it's like harder on women i think
than it is on men
because we're more emotional when we
take things personally like it's like
trained out of me
because of my dad to care so like
i might have cared a lot at one point
and don't get me wrong i don't enjoy
being insulted but like you had to train
yourself not to care but it's just like
a weird phenomenon
where at a certain level
you hear so many things through the
grapevine everyone's got an opinion on
you and it's like
or before no one cared you existed
and even though you have a whole new
level of success the whole level of
success comes with a whole different set
of problems and [ __ ] you're stressed
about which you weren't stressed out
about before
and i'm grateful for all for all of it i
am so so incredibly grateful you don't
even understand but
i cry sometimes
anyways
um this is just a short
video about i don't know i just try to
make these videos so i can look back
along the way
and
see what i was thinking
and also
be grateful because at different points
in life like
i don't know
i have youth right now and youth is like
the most valuable thing you can have
right
well
anyways guys don't forget to subscribe
to the channel
bring that notification bell
please sign up for our memberships okay
i don't even know if i said anything
this yeah
bye love you bye